foreign
[Music]
cast number 11. my name is John Striker
Meyer Welcome to our show today
and we're talking uh where this
presentation is coming to you courtesy
of Jacob Productions and saw Chronicles
and I'm going to turn to uh across the
fence it's one of our more uh surreal
stories of my entire 19 months in
Vietnam
and it starts doing a Recon a six-man
Recon team is in Laos and their under
enemy attack
and during the next NVA wave attack
Boggs Pete Boggs was the team leader
he called in an airstrike
he told the A1 Sky breeders to hit his
Recon team which was code name St
Louisiana
to break the charge
the first 20 Mike Mike gun run ripped
into the NBA and through St Louisiana's
perimeter
Tom Cunningham the radio operator was in
a world of [ __ ] and there was nothing he
could do about it
the next thing he knew he was a hundred
yards away
watching himself get hit twice
one round went through his right leg
one went through the radio on his back
although the radio was destroyed
it saved Cunningham's life
bogs got hit with shrapnel from the
exploding PRC 25.
the Vietnamese team member who was
sitting where Walton had been
was killed instantly
the rounds detonated the frag the smoke
grenade and the Cs tier gas grenades on
the dead indigenous Soldier
more shrapnel knocked Boggs into
semi-unconsciousness
the gun run broke the NBA wave attacks
against St Louisiana
it also left the team in a plume of tear
gas and smoke
if I smoke grenades weapons fire and the
earlier Napalm run
the NBA probably felt the conditions
around the team perimeter were far more
deadly
than facing the gun runs from the spads
Walton performed a quick triage on Boggs
and Cunningham
he found that while the explosion of the
20 mic Mike round had left behind only a
piece of single flesh or signed to
holding the leg together it has seared a
good section portion of Cunningham's
wound right leg
actually helping the situation by
keeping the loss of blood to a minimum
the medic pulled out a green Corvette
for a tourniquet he used his knife
to twist the bandage tight above the
stump to stem any further bleeding
Walton also treated Cunningham for
severe
throat burn from the Cs gas
so this is from chapter four and across
the fence and we're going to get into
much more detail about that day
and the past couple of episodes of
sawcast
we've had men that served in SOG for
over three years
today we're honored to have with us Tom
Cunningham
who served actually three days
a short period of time and welcome sir
thank you and uh it is one of the most
unusual stories during my entire time of
my 19 months in the secret war and so
Tom and I since uh August the 3rd 1968
we met then probably at the hospital
after you came back correct and then
from there we've moved forward ever
since but this attack
the unusual aspect of it was your
personal experience and when I put the
book together I'll never forget
interviewing you Europe and New
Hampshire I'm in California it's like
four o'clock in the morning because
you're an early riser in New Hampshire
and we're talking about this and you
told me for the first time about you're
out of Body Experience
and uh I like to go back to a little bit
more of the book than you can fill us in
on more of the details because this is
still one of the most unusual stories
so you are again
the team had been attacked several wave
attacks a six-man Recon team in Laos you
only been on the ground maybe an hour or
so correct when they came at you yes and
so after several wave attacks the team
leader box called that airstrike on his
own team to break the enemy attack which
in of itself
is an unusual occasion but the team
leader made that decision based on the
exigent circumstances
and when we left Tom
body was literally lifted off the ground
and when that happened he had an
out-of-body experience and returning to
the book just for a second
Cunningham still watching himself from
far away
he heard someone on a radio calling
Covey saying they were too dead
he thought he'd better find out whether
or not he was alive
the Green Beret had a unique test to
find out he yelled
it sounded like it was far far away
but he knew that he was alive
the yell also ended Cunningham's Out of
Body Experience
he returned to his body lying on the
ground
and Cunningham knew they had to help
himself the more he did
the better it would be for everyone
my God Tom
and what was I mean what was that moment
like flying through the air without the
greatest defeat and you're watching
yourself I mean we've heard about out of
body experiences
about this
just prior to being hit I felt this
how you get that sixth sense of you're
in trouble oh yes okay uh and
something's going wrong so I tried to
find the source of danger
and a Twist a little bit I couldn't find
anything the next thing I know
I if you can imagine yourself being a
Chinese gong and having somebody come up
and strike that gong that was not once
but twice yes so I felt this big
vibration go through my body
and at that point
the essence of me whoever I am left my
physical body I could actually
be an observer of what was happening to
me as I
through this cloud of smoke and it's
flew through the air landed on the
ground but even as you're flying you
could tell that your leg had been
severed but it was hanging on by sinu
yes yeah you could see the legs separate
uh and and that itself is a shocking
experience uh to say the least uh
but that essence of being
connected to your body Maybe by a thread
but you're out of the body and you're
not really experiencing
part of you experiencing what's going on
and the other part is not it's watching
what is going on
uh and that's when I uh landed uh
outside our perimeter
I had no idea whether I was alive or not
I really did not when I heard you're
still watching yourself you're not sure
I'm not sure
uh I'm not saying this you know the
great white lights and all this other no
I just
watching the field around me develop
um
and that's when I heard uh
the Como up to Covey
and I'm sitting there going I know I'm
hurt okay I know I've lost my leg I
don't know whether I'm alive or not and
I'm hearing this well there's two other
or at least two dead yeah and at that
point we had already suffered one in
ditch casually yeah so I know we were
down to
three active people maybe
or not
and that's when I decided that
I would test if I figured if I could
hear myself yo
then I had to be alive
I I have no idea where that came from
but if I could hear myself yell then I
must be alive still with this so I
yelled and as your book mentions it was
like somebody at the far end of a
football field yelling yeah oh my God
but the minute I heard my voice yeah it
snapped me like a rubber band snapped me
right back into my body and so I've kept
this just for this moment in time
just in case anybody has a doubt this is
a 20 millimeter round
check its size and shape two of which
hit you August the 3rd 1968 on top of a
Knoll yep in Laos and he's around to
talk about it today that in and of
itself
is just remarkable
and uh so you're you come back you are
alive and at some point John came out to
you
yeah from that point on I will go I'm in
and out of Consciousness or
there is I have clear memories of some
things and I have a vague memory of
others and other gaps have been filled
by other people telling me what went on
uh but yes I got dragged back into the
inside of the perimeter
uh John put on the tourniquet and then
because of the surges of enemy forces
against us everybody
had to do their job yeah and I knew that
that at that point my job was to not be
a burden on anybody else
that I had to take care of myself as
much as possible until we got out
assuming we could get out at that point
getting out was very questionable it was
so let me just back the tape up a little
bit uh this is August the 3rd 1968 by
this time the secret War had been going
on for four years
and
um
the secret War involved missions going
across the fence into layoffs of
Cambodia to see what enemy soldiers were
up to and so this was one of those
missions and was St Louisiana and at
that time in 68 there were six different
uh fobs for an operating bases in
Vietnam from which
the Green Berets ran missions across the
fence into Cambodia Laos or North
Vietnam so this day that mission was to
go into that Target area which was on
the ashaw valley the west side of the
astral Valley I believe correct and um
the mission was to go in to find do you
remember what the mission itself was
well I knew part of the mission was
there was a ArcLight scheduled
two days after we were scheduled to come
out and part of our mission was to
determine whether it was still a viable
Target area oh is that right I missed
that part
so it was for our listeners an arc light
is a B-52 bombing raid indeed yes
and uh so the other aspect of this story
is
as I in the opening we said others have
been in for three years in your case we
know of at least three days when did you
officially arrive at fubai because this
was August the 3rd I believe was a
Saturday I'm not sure I'd been in um
uh I got to know I'm early July
July 1 July 2 right around that area
and processed through uh I'm not I don't
even know how long I was yeah maybe
maybe a week uh plus or minus what I
know is when I got assigned to fubai and
got assigned to uh Louisiana
the team had already been signed this
target site
and I was the plan had been in this or
what I was told don't worry about it
you're too new you won't be going out
right so it's just going to be Boggs and
Tony Harrell
we're going to go out with the indige
and then Tony transferred to the Como
shaft
while I was
just trying to orient myself to being
the info by so
I got elevated to the 1-1 position and
this
mission was still going to go
and thank God somebody woke up and said
we can't put an FNG in yeah as a [ __ ]
new guy yeah that's the one one thank
you very much you're good enough to
carry your radio but not yeah we need a
little bit more experience on that and
that's when they uh pulled in John
Walton to be the one one on the team so
we went in uh I was told we went in
heavy three Americans and three in ditch
indeed uh
guys we were
Pro ready to go it was going to be Boggs
had planned to do a last Light insert
right so we took two slides because we
couldn't get in at last Light because of
the weather uh in the ash Hall did you
actually launch in the weather we never
got off the launch line right okay yeah
the weather closed us out twice
and so they decide what we'll try it
first light insert and avoid and avoid
the weather that worked yes the good
news is it worked the bad news is it
worked
it worked very well uh but we went in uh
on
uh-34s
two of us per uh-34 and they even had I
mean I was surprised that they had three
three King bees the code name for the
Vietnamese ch34s
which were the old Sikorsky uh
helicopters or King bees and they're
flown by the 219th Special Operations
Squadron in the South Vietnamese Air
Force that were just uh amazing pilots
and we'll get into more details about
Captain 10 a little later down the down
the road here but uh and then also very
skilled up aviators oh and fearless
um and then uh you had also
um met John Walton back when you're
going through training group or one face
yes so at least you knew each other a
little bit we had casually uh he was
friends with uh a couple of people in my
squad room uh for lack of I don't know
what we call the bay areas but College
Squad room uh who are ahead of me in uh
training group
so I knew him by sight I knew him by
name right so when we re-med up at fubai
we at least
knew each other to say hi
I remember you yeah uh so we weren't
total strangers at that particular Point
well and also you know a lot of people
don't know how when you come in the
country
sometimes even if your special forces
you can get diverted elsewhere yes and
even with so when you landed a camera on
Bay you learned there were orders that
were going to ship you to a conventional
unit
and how'd you get out of that uh we
found the uh sfnco lesion and said help
I hadn't wanted to go through all of
training group and everything to get to
Nam right uh and then get diverted to a
conventional unit so I wanted to get
back into an SF unit
and the options were
I won't say great they were how would
you like to go to stock not knowing what
it is thank you very much and you know
conventional unit or SOG and I said well
I'll do SOG thank you very much
that's when you go back to the trang
have your in-country training yes and he
said that is that what they called to be
is that called the recondo school to
talk I forgot what the name was I know
we did in country training I just forgot
it was uh the trang we uh the in-country
orientation or training was uh conducted
at the McBee recondo School
oh okay
um and not necessarily in conjunction
with other classes there but in our own
bubble right
um and maybe a week long
uh accumulating with a uh
small Recon Patrol or a patrol out onto
entree Island
um getting live fire during your job no
we did not we had a couple of heat
exhaustion cases that was the most
serious
serious thing yeah because that's July
yes that is Summer and you run into
secondary jungle growth and that's a
real uh difficult uh barrier to get
through welcome to wait a minute Vines
yes
oh man okay so uh from there
um
did you go to Danang get your top secret
briefing yeah first yeah I went to from
and then trying to denang uh State I
don't know why we stayed overnight at
house 22. right uh and the sfc safe
house in Danang yep yeah and then
processed over to uh the SF compound in
Danang so you remember your top secret
briefing yes I was quite impressed with
the um
flow of the quick flow of information
that you got it was very professionally
presented as a lot of military briefings
are yeah
and uh you're not overwhelmed but
they're putting up the whole uh
organizational uh
chart so to speak of what SOG was and
how it was organized and that was after
you signed a non-dis non-disclosure
agreement yes and you've already and
they give you a little code book to you
know what's your code what code name do
you want thank you very much we got to
assign you one of these code names
uh
and you go through at that point they
were you go also through a small
interview where are you going to stay in
Danang uh and maybe uh work kamo uh
because that because when you went
through special forces training that was
your final MOS no you started and then
weapons
oh really you have to blow things up I
could blow things up thank you very much
I got blown up instead yeah oh no oh
hey you put it out there sir indeed
indeed
but uh no I found uh I had originally
gone to the training group for o5b Komo
right and then I found that I was having
a difficult time reaching the uh send
and receive standards at that point it
was good of 1818 right capability and I
got to 1716. right which means you had
to serve because with Morse code they
have five letter groups and you had to
receive and send 18 one minute yes wpm
words word groups per minute and that's
why I got recycled me McIntyre Rick
asked this and a few others got all got
recycled because that was hard training
but oh it's 16 17 receiving yeah it
sounds to me it started sounding like a
solid line of sound thank you very much
I could not tell a dit from a DAT from a
space and time thank you very much so
off to engineer hearing and then uh
um that must have been a lot of fun
though oh I kind of blow stuff up I
think engineering is uh I've been
attracted to things that go bang indeed
so that was a natural substitute for
kamo right
at that particular point so and then you
get assigned to carry a radio on sock
right so getting back to your briefing
what was that like
and then out of that then how do you get
your assignment to fob1 well we went
through uh like I said we I can remember
you know in processing is standing in
line you're going through uh there's a
couple officers that are interviewing
you
and I can remember the comment standing
out well you know if you had a little
bit more experience we have a slot for a
Demoman but you don't
so you're going to fubai oh is that
right yeah okay and I said okay you're
going to run Recon and fubai yeah and I
said that was
uh no choice I know I didn't expect any
choice you're sitting there here's my
orders you hand them your your file and
they look at it very quickly and say
okay if some of the common guys I know
stayed right in Danang they were at the
Como Shack in today before they went on
any of the Recon teams right oh yeah so
some guys were in the comment Shack for
a long time before he got on every young
team
indeed but you avoided that yeah right
up right on the Recon team in fact
that's one of the quickest you know you
come on the team maybe we'll just say
for today's discussion
on that Thursday you're on a team you'd
get a briefing on Friday and they try to
do tonight in search but you get
weathered out maybe maybe twice two days
in a row two days in a row okay Thursday
and Friday get weathered out and then
Saturday morning it's showtime yep uh
first light and uh a key thing here
because August the 3rd the mountain
ranges and layoffs were high and you've
inserted on a Knoll and they plan to
take three helicopters they had the old
ch40 34s right and so two Americans one
American an indigenous and indigen the
first one would be Pete his and ditch
the second helicopter you were on that
one with another ditch and then Walton
was on the third for the insertion right
and even there I think you said you
heard a couple of rounds that were fired
at the helicopter no I I did not okay I
thought we got in pretty cleanly okay
um you know they they were sad they
sandwiched me between Pete and John for
a reason okay
experience the experience in no guy
right with the experience but we got off
the landing Zone
uh hit the tree line went into the tree
line and uh laid quiet for
several minutes quite quite a bit of
time in fact when we released the
Choppers because after you're on the
ground after insert you wait about 10
minutes yeah hear how it's going on and
then you give a team okay and you're the
radio guy you did it yeah and Pete
wanted to wait longer than that just to
be cya yes sure this was we had
anticipated the target area to be
extremely hot
uh we actually had anticipated not being
able to get in getting shot out of the
LZ
that uh anticipation didn't happen but
Pete held the cubby over us in the air
assets on site for
long enough that when we said Team okay
they said what took you so long we were
worried about you oh is that right yes
okay yeah and uh again for for
background purposes Pete by that point
have been a veteran recomb and he had
run missions out of case on with fob 3
and then when they closed fob3 Pete came
down to Foo fight if we'll be won and
then he became the team leader and then
we had that change of membership on the
team you came on and John I think he by
that point John had run running two
missions with another team so he had
some experience on the ground but more
importantly he was a damn good medic yes
and needed
oh yeah and so
um when you're on the ground you get in
you give the team okay and then we start
moving uphill uh we actually ran into a
a barrier of
booby traps booby really yes almost like
it would say uh well almost like it was
their equivalent of a Gabriel
demonstration I saw so many different
types of booby traps uh in a short area
and it was only 25 maybe 50 yards deep
at best really were there any that
include The Punchy pits yep oh there was
some dead Falls yeah
there was some other
booby traps that uh I would say they
were the equivalent of bouncing betties
I mean you could see that they were if
you sat on them you were going to set
off and a Bouncing Betty is an explosive
that launches in the air then it
explodes about three feet for more
lethality
takes out you from the waist down thank
you
yeah so we made it through there
and
we actually did we did not know that at
that time we started to parallel a
a running path
because we took a break to do a commode
check to get a hold of um
well the code name at that point for us
was Alexander which was the a wax fly
flying over us okay yeah so we're trying
to make contact with them when a small
team of NBA walked down the path
that we were parallel to really yeah
and again that was one of the clarity
moments of
you're I'm running the radio and I'm
whispering to Alexander trying to make
first contact with him yeah and he said
you got to speak up you got to speak up
sounds like you're whispering
you know no I'm sorry speak up I can't
right now yeah not not right this minute
so they continued back towards uh they
were actually running down apparently to
the LZ that we landed on I mean that's
the direction they were traveling while
we were going uphill
and this is parallel yeah
and they didn't see you at that they did
not see us at that time
uh we went for another maybe 10 20
minutes at Mo maybe 10 15 minutes and
then took another break stopped to
listen
uh that is uh when one of the indige on
the team saw off to our left off uh a
bunker line
and while we're trying to figure out
what we were going to do how we were
going to circumvent this bunker
is when a Tracker came and shot up our
rear guard
right and so that was where that's the
first Combat on that mission which was
um
going back to the book for a second
Walton was sitting at the end of the
formation in a thick jungle vegetation
while the tail Gunner
with the tail Gunner
they were both surprised to hear
numerous NVA soldiers moving along the
trail
then that noise got the Gunner's
attention he focused on the area to his
right Walton was sitting in front of him
with the remaining four team members
spread out in front of the two of them
as the tailgunner continued to
concentrate on the woods to the right
Walton
looked past him and saw the Bush's Shake
about 10 feet away
one of the NBA soldiers was crawling up
their back Trail
as Walton swung his car 15 toured the
enemy soldier the NVA popped up
AK-47 tucked under his arm
he had a big Cheshire Cat grin on his
face knowing that he had St Louisiana
dead to rights
the grinning Soldier opened fire on full
automatic
while Walton was still turning
four of the NBA rounds struck the tail
Gunner wounding him severely
Walton's car 15 rounds hit the NBA
Soldier and drove his body backwards
into the jungle
with the threat temporarily at Bay he
began to patch up the tail Gunner
Walton dragged him six feet up the hill
towards Boggs got him stabilized and
started an IV an intervened intra-venous
drip of blood expander
Walton asked Boggs for permission to
crawl back to the dead NVA to search for
documents and anything of intelligence
values
Boggs rightfully declined the offer
moments later the first NVA wave attack
slammed into Louisiana
the six-man team repulsed it without
taking any further casualties
did you you heard the gunfire exchange
and with the vegetation thick enough
that you couldn't see what was going on
until John dragged the comrade back to
that perimeter where he was you couldn't
see exactly what was happening is that
Twilight Zone stuff or what yes yeah and
he grabbed him and pulled him in and
then we moved a little bit when he got
him inside our perimeters yeah and
that's when we got started to be heavily
engaged and so what was that wave attack
like
well the first time uh
that's a hard thing to say uh because
you didn't have a chance to put claimers
or anything no we just had our
our rifles our 15s trusty car 15s they
worked
um and part of it was they weren't
exactly sure where we were
so I don't think they brought their
whole Force to bear on us the first uh
first couple of times right
so we've had the advantage of of having
limited numbers coming at us so again
the jungle is thick you're in double
canopy or triple canopy at that point we
moved out of that canopy okay the
initial contact started in the jungle
right and then we uh dragged everybody
out to a clearing and called for Medevac
right and that's when we get started to
get hit again and so when that first hit
was like Lily a wave of soldiers Envy
soldiers come out it was like
sporadically it was sporadic guys coming
out but still it's like Welcome to the
Jungle baby yeah uh like I said we were
very it was not a coordinated attack on
our position because right they weren't
sure exactly where we were sure and when
we moved we lost they lost track of
where we were
so you're able to repulse it yes and
John took care of the of the tail Gunner
and so by now you're on the radio we got
a prairie fire emergency we needed a
Medevac and Pete is keeping an eye on
the situation then another wave attack
comes they had you moved at all before
in between tax yes yeah we had moved
after the first one uh and uh
trying to get a better position in the
in a open field where we could bring in
some uh the Medevac helicopter
so uh
we called in uh we got the 101st
gunships over us relatively quickly
right okay and they were able to make
gun runs it took some of the pressure
off they took a great deal of pressure
off because at that particular point the
NVA were more concentrated on trying to
shoot down the helicopters
than they were on us right and there was
an up across the valley or
uh not from behind us but from in front
of where we were going uh
they had put an NBA unit online
and so every time the chopper came down
the Ridgeline
to make a gun pass you could hear this
whole Ridgeline open up on the on the
wall no kidding and every time they did
that the Ridgeline was closer
find that Firing Line and you just hear
the progress of that coming down the uh
towards you towards us yes we knew what
was coming yeah and that was also part
of that theory about getting close to
the Belt yes the enemy gets close to
your belt to avoid getting hit by air
assets yes that uh attack air
it avoids are or try they try to
neutralize our air superiority by coming
in and kissing you hello staying as
close to you as they possibly can so
again we had a little section in the
book here about you and those opening
moments where after they arrived
um
every time they flew by for the gun run
the NVA and the Ridgeline would jump up
and Fire
Cunningham crawled to a Knoll to get a
better view because it was his first
contact with the NVA the dirt in front
of his face exploded several times from
enemy rounds
Cunningham suddenly thought maybe that
wasn't such a good idea as he backed up
real fast after a few more close gun
runs the helicopters had expended all of
their ordinance and returned to base of
operations at fubai
Cunningham jokingly asked the 101st
Gunners if they could come just come on
down and pull them out
the gunships declined saying the
extraction helicopters were on the way
a few minutes later Cunningham was told
the A1 Sky readers were on station
Boggs had asked for a Napalm run
Walton was sitting next to Cunningham on
his right and had just finished patching
up the last of the tail Gunner's wounds
both men were near a clearing Boggs
directed The Napalm run which struck the
ground at the far end of the open area
and moved towards St Louisiana on the
Knoll
Walton didn't think about anything about
it often the distance he could see the
spad making its run saw the cash to come
loose from the aircraft and tumbled down
towards Earth
after the Napalm Caster hit the ground
and exploded its forward momentum
carried a one foot hunk of burning metal
up the Knoll over the open area towards
Walton and I guess you were sitting
there together yes you're watching all
this too correct and his team has
stopped right between Walton's feet
he sat there staring at it the burning
metal between his legs for a few seconds
Cunningham was amazed at how close it
was I mean my God and he got splashed on
the on his arm with it I can remember
Walton knocking off the Napalm office no
off his sleeve
and because Napalm if you don't knock it
off it'll burn until it burns itself out
so you either have to smuggle with the
or something otherwise it's going to
continue to burn and it has burned
through people's limbs yes oh he was I
won't say casual about it but it's just
brushing off his sleeve
that's what you call about danger close
air support it is dangerous and it is
close very close and you watched all
this yep oh
any I just can't imagine
we've done Napalm but I never ever had
anything that close with a with that
from the Napalm explosion I just can't
imagine
it's it's hard to imagine I mean it's
hard to put into words if you but it's
you're experiencing it I mean you're
it's just part of what you're dealing
with at that present moment oh my God
you don't have time to think about the
real impact of what is going on oh sure
yeah so you all watch that survive it
yeah yeah and besides the the Envy are
coming further down the null each time
there's a gun run closer to you all yep
and this is highly visible
yeah and at that point they they were
there wasn't a lot of distance between
us and them physically distance right uh
they had uh overrun us a couple of times
at that particular point
and we'd beat them back with small arms
fire that's why we brought in the spats
uh right uh as close as we did
so then uh it was at that point at some
point uh John went back to to Boggs and
uh the I think Pete directed him to go
back to the tail Gunner's position
because that point of your that at that
point that's part of your perimeter
nobody was there that's correct so John
moved back to the other side of the
perimeter and you here crawled about
eight feet down a slight slope when a
second NVA wave hit the team from bogg's
side near the point
again St Louisiana held as another wave
of NVA moved towards the team bogg began
to yell to his men that they were being
overrun
from his position only eight feet away
Walton couldn't see Boggs or Cunningham
or the Vietnamese team member who had
filled the slot that he John had vacated
the jungle vegetation was so thick he
could only see one or two feet around
him in fact the foleys were so thick
Walton would see the leaves move first
to announce an incoming enemy soldier
good God that was one of my first
experiences in getting overrun was you
could see the the leaves move hell yeah
that's something a lot of times the
fireplace because you're in the jungle
the leave movement
or the AK rounds coming out of those
leaves and you could see the uh the gas
from the expulsion of the gas from the
firearms pushing the leaves aside
so you can watch them vibe as they're
firing you watch the leaves move them of
the fire
so then going on so John is only eight
feet away but he can't see y'all
that's just again another indication of
what the jungle you you're in but you
can from where you and Pete and the
remaining uh
team members
could see and then that Pete announced
that that they're going to call a gun
run at some point on the team because
there's another wave attack on you all
uh at that particular point where uh
I mean
before we got that far uh
one of the indige had the uh m79 was an
m79 Gunner
and he had expanded all of his m79 ammo
really yeah so he was working the signal
panel to try to Mark the team location
for the spads right so he was behind
behind me
um
and uh
after the Napalm Run Pete decided that
we were going to try to blow a hole
through their line and as any through
that hole so we're gonna
dump our rocks and at the conclusion of
the of the uh gun run
and so and then use the air strike to
blow a hole in their ranks so you could
e e escape and evade through that hole
that's correct whoa
oh
so by that point you're taking but you
start the rucksack on yes I still have
the radio on so we were not going to
dump Rock and I don't think we were
going to leave
I had no intention leaving the radio I
mean oh yeah so um
and we're gonna just run for it at that
particular point
the air assets are uh uh-34s had not
arrived that we didn't know when they
were coming
um
and uh we were going to do our best to
get out of that
and so again it's just a This Moment In
Time
he did Pete say we're calling a gun run
or give you guys any kind of a heads up
yes well I I don't know how much uh John
knew right but Pete turned to me and
said would what we were going to do he's
going to call in the gun run danger
close yeah uh do an he drop and we would
uh try to evade
from that point so be ready yeah you
know and so this is that point box
called in the airstrike
and told the spads to hit St Louisiana
to hit his team to break the next charge
the first 20 Mike Mike gun run ripped
into the NVA and threw St Louisiana's
perimeter
Cunningham was in a world of [ __ ] and
there was nothing he could do about it
the next thing he knew he was a hundred
yards away watching himself get hit
twice
oh sorry it's a little bit redundant but
that moment in time is just so amazing
um so there you are you're 100 yards
away we're back at that moment in your
life and I'm outside the perimeter yeah
and I don't know whether I'm alive or
dead right
oh my God and uh
like unfortunately I think fortunately
for everybody we didn't know whether we
were going to get obviously whether we
were going to get out or not sure at
that particular point and I knew and it
is redundant to say I knew that if I was
alive I had to be not a drag on the team
but I had to be a help to the team
oh yeah so I was motivated by the only
way we're going to get out is if I can
contribute to
here you are severely wounded but you're
still like you still have the Soldier's
attitude what's best for the team and
you did it and uh remember at that point
you were not thinking about yourself
you're thinking about the the cohesive
unit you know even though your leg your
your right leg lower right leg is
dangling from sinu and you got shrapnel
in your back from the uh 20 mic Mike
around tearing up your PRC 25 you're
doing what's best for the team and so
just as a little sidebar at that time I
remember that day personally because we
were at fubai back to the base camp
safely in Scots but we had heard that
the team was in a world of [ __ ] and back
enough will be one most of the spike
team members were either huddled around
their PC prc25s listening to Covey
talking to St Louisiana members or in
the com Center where they monitor more
frequencies and when the first reports
rolled in from Covey about St Louisiana
situation
the team sounded doomed
in the ashaw valley the airstrikes gave
St Louisiana a brief Lull in the
fighting enabling Walton and the one
remaining on wounded Vietnamese team
member
to move the Moon closer to the clearing
Pat Watkins who was the cubby Rider at
that time
told Walton that he was going to direct
a series of strafing runs by Air Force
F4 Phantom Jets and that the first kingb
would land to pick up the most seriously
wounded and that is second and a third
h-34 would extract the remainder of the
team
Walton and the Vietnamese team member
moved the tail Gunner out from the tree
line into the grassy area while Boggs
assisted Cunningham as soon as the NBA
heard the king be the enemy activity
picked up again the wounded were moved
out to the open area where the grass was
only six inches tall
there were constant dirt spurts kicking
up all around from enemy gunfire Captain
tin piloted the first king bee and
landed with the right strut only a few
feet from the wounded members
and so getting back to you and your
personal experiences this is another
sidebar on what you went through that
day it's kind of like there were only
three times Cunningham really felt pain
that day the first time was when he got
hit
he said later that his body felt like
one of those used like you said earlier
today the Chinese gongs as the shock
raise reverberated through your body the
second time was when Boggs was helping
you get back to the landing Zone your
wounded leg got caught on a tree yes
good God
so you immediately knew that meant that
when they said pain had Kellers
quote Cunningham saw a rainbow of Keller
yes yep yeah getting that leg hung up on
us Robin was
I really had left in between the two I I
really was not in a great deal of pain
yeah I'm not going to say I wasn't in
shock and I was in and out of things uh
but that was the next big wave of of
pain oh my God to this day it's kind of
still Vivid in your memory I'm assuming
yes
and then uh when Boggs just at you to
get on a king bee he turned around to
fire at the charging NVA Cunningham
didn't want to get shot in the back so
he used his stump to climb aboard the
h-34 he crawled to the back of the
chopper thinking he was finally safe
the king be lifted off
so that was the third time you got hurt
getting in the chopper yes it ripped off
uh tore off the cauterization that had
occurred on the Blake oh uh and it was
if you talk about Lessons Learned yeah
uh Lessons Learned was I was not safe in
the chopper
uh and uh
so I crawled to the what I thought was
the back of the chopper and tried to
tend for myself as much as I could but
at that point I was losing I was
bleeding out I was losing blood right
were you able to work on your tourniquet
at all nope I was barely able to
maintain Consciousness so Captain tin
takes off with you and Pete
again because of the height of the
mountains the heat of the day the first
plan was they knew that the helicopters
are going to carry so much weight
correct in this case it was two people
you and the ditch that was shot four
times that John had passed up and John
worked on you but he's now the bleeding
begins again
and when you took off did you realize
that other helicopters were trying to
get in and couldn't uh no the rest of
what happens after that is what
everybody else has really told me what
has happened after that and at some
point your king bee turns around and
goes back yes
dude what was that like you talk about
the you know this good luck bad luck and
fortunes of whatever uh but if it had if
the plan had worked as envisioned I
would have bled out before we got any
place is that right yeah I wouldn't be
here wow uh so with the other king bees
not able to come down because the
intense fire from the NBA uh Captain
Ting brought us back down yeah and the
rest of the team got on board and that
is when Walton again put on a tourniquet
on my leg so listen so we just run
through as a second king we try to get
and get shot out right a third King be
tries again it gets shot out Captain tin
hears this circles back comes in and
picks him up because at that point you
know after the the first couple of ships
Walton felt sick now he's on the grounds
just him the indige and Pete Boggs who's
wounded seriously wounded and the one
other team member who's not wounded and
still just a Fearless Warrior yeah we
had one in ditch get out without a
scratch yeah which I understand if again
he had been he saved our Bots oh yeah I
mean for lack of better characterization
indeed uh he was the only one who was
really uninjured and totally Mobile on
this
at that particular point
oh my God he and John
and so John the question of the weight
had forced the team to leave the dead
Vietnamese team member behind
his added weight might hinder the
chances of the living team members
through successfully be exfiltrated
so Walton is counterpart scanned the sky
for the helicopter but none were in
sight then he heard on the radio
King B go down
Captain tin said this and the radio as
he came down and landed right next to
where John was
and at that point in time the enemy were
closing in on John the indige and Pete
correct and so
um they get aboard
and again we're at that point in time
where the king bee can't take off are
you aware of just how of all these
Dynamics could you hear the gunfire I
can hear the gunfire and I can I know
the team is coming on board right I
didn't know that you know the plan had
been to take me away and not come back
and pick up the team uh so uh no I was
very much aware that we had come back
down and uh picked up the remaining part
of the team
our the flight out I'm not aware of okay
because after Walton puts on uh the
tourniquet I think I go and
I don't have a good memory so I expected
that particular Point well at that point
a shock you're in and out of shock yep
and like you said you're losing blood
fortunately like you said as it turns
out for you John gets on a helicopter
while Captain tennis trying to take off
he's working on your leg yep and working
on saving your life
and again we're back to the whole weight
heat issue and of the h34 has struts on
the side with wheels correct and so
um Captain 10 realized that the weight
he couldn't lift off so he lifted the
back wheel of the helicopter off the
ground started rolling downhill gaining
as much air speed as possible while the
NVA fired at the chopper
at the last possible moment 10 nursed
the Aging Sikorsky over the trees
unfortunately the chopper didn't have
enough speed to gain altitude needed to
fly out of the mountains so Captain tin
dipped down into a valley to build up
more speed all while under enemy gunfire
and then he took a couple of laps do you
remember any of that or just by now
you're heading back to fubai by by by
that time I am pretty much unconscious
so I don't remember any of the
particulars of of that
what I my next conscious memory is uh
being stripped my clothing while I'm in
the in the chopper was that right so
they're taking off uh and I can't tell
you who's doing it sure but uh they're
taking off my gear taking off my
clothing uh so by the time we arrive at
the hospital I am
as I was born thank you very much minus
a leg bare ass and naked to the world
because your fatigues are also pretty
well shot up between the rounds and
everything else and the bleeding yes and
so John it had to be John and his and
ditch helping to get you out of the
clothes realizing
they had to have you bare surface
they've got to be checking for wounds
that other wounds and stuff like that at
that particular point
and then what I remember is when we
landed the medical staff met us at the
you know came out yeah to the chopper
and I'm being pulled off and it had to
be a Doctor Who's
who who criticized the uh placement of
the tourniquet the tourniquette was too
high yeah yeah too high
you know that's surprising what you do
remember
oh my God
and then the second thing his comment
was the intuitive obvious you know
you've lost your leg young man no yes
I said okay
I'm sorry I don't mean to laugh but this
is no bedside manner it's not yes thank
you very much
and uh see here when uh uh so you're
being attended to bare ass naked
by a doctor and
Walton and the uninjured Vietnamese team
member
carried the wound of Vietnamese team
member into the Army Medical Facility
and someone told Walton that they didn't
treat Vietnamese there
Walton told them to treat that
Vietnamese or there would be hell to pay
yep
God do you remember any of that I
remember uh the aftermath of that
because as they started getting fluids
into me I became more conscious yeah
yeah and the Vietnamese was two beds
over from me
at that particular point and again you
know you and I are are big fans of John
Walton for being a the epitome of a good
Green Beret medic
and uh but for John even though you're
beginning to recoup and come back to
your senses a little bit with the IV for
John the drama continued
when they got Cunningham inside he was
barely hanging on due to the loss of
blood and Trauma one of the young
doctors got nervous
he had never had a dirty sweaty grunt
just out of the field sticking his nose
into his business
oh my God so when Cunningham's pressure
was so low they couldn't get an IV into
him Walton told the doctor to do a cut
down
cut into the vein expose it
stick a catheter into it and tie it off
with a suture
and John did it
because the doctor was too shaky yeah
it's surprising you're in a combat
hospital and the doctor doesn't have
that
maybe he was an FNG yeah no kidding
and then the doctor soon realized that
medic wasn't leaving
oh
oh so um
no and there was one other point in
there
any other burning memories from that
moment I know at uh in that well one
minute while I'm in the hospital in the
bed yeah uh John comes over Walton comes
over and wants to know if I'd
did I see how what Pete did
because he was at that point very he
impressed me that he had been impressed
by what Pete did right oh sure uh and
how he said did you see his eyes you
know
and the intensity of that
and I had at that point no I didn't
you're a little busy yeah yeah
oh my God and then uh
um so from your personal experience from
there they clean you up Pat you up
and then you stayed overnight then uh
the uh
rest of the indigenous team came down
first
I just and came in to see how I was
right
um and we talked for a little bit
my sense of time here is totally bizarre
you know oh wow yeah and then they went
over and they uh talked to the other our
other indigenous teammate uh to see how
he was doing while they were doing that
uh the rest of the guys from the fob
came down including uh Colonel Warren
well he came up from today yeah yeah so
he came in no kidding yeah I'd forgotten
that they want to know what what he
could do for me at that particular Point
whoa
and I had an absolutely ridiculous
request which I don't have to repeat
here
had to do with an alcoholic beverage
which would not have helped me at all
but they ended up bringing down a carton
of cigarettes for me uh
a medic that I didn't know uh Gordon
Martin yeah uh gave me his lighter for
the cigarettes and I think they brought
a six pack of beer is that right yeah
yeah okay and the following morning I
left the hospital with the lighter I
don't know where the beer went don't
know where the cigarettes went but I had
the lighter he kept the lighter well the
lighter was in my hand you still have it
to this day I have it to this day and if
Gordon never hears this and wants it
it's his
I thought so according to the booker
this could be a little wrong but uh
didn't they try to slip in a favorite
whiskey
well I asked you asked you tried I tried
because uh what I remember was because
we're still relatively new ourselves so
we were several guys that went over with
John to go back on Sunday morning to
visit you all because I remember God
knew Pete yeah because Pete and I had
just from being a camp together and you
were still had just come in and all of a
sudden you have this unique moment in
time and thank God you're still alive
you're the the sog Miracle Man yes not
too many people get hit
with this indeed and live to talk about
it and this never might hit with two 20
Mike Mike round
just think about that for a second hit
with two
oh my God the 220 Mike Mike man either
that or a Miracle Man whichever one you
like better I care I went out and bought
myself a couple of oh is that right mics
that I think I'm going to add to uh my
motorcycle
huh remind me of how lucky I was well
yeah and then uh more than luck it was
based on everybody else doing their job
and doing it well
oh yeah because if everybody else had
not done their job and done it well
again I wouldn't be here because even
after Pete's wounded and John's moving
him back
to the uh potential LZ
for the kingb to come in I mean he's
still firing away fighting and now the
guy the tail Gunner who was shot four
times he's just trying to stay alive but
he did yeah John saved him and you and
of course Pete he had serious shrapnel
wounds but uh nothing as serious as
yours and it's just one more little
sidebar uh from that day uh regarding
John that I just wanted to get into
later that night and again I'll never
forget it because we're at the poker
table with John
and uh
after he had showered and shaved we're
playing poker at the Green Beret Lounge
at F will be one
being left-handed when John dealt a hand
of Poker
he held the deck
in his right hand
as he dealt the cards across the table
someone noticed a flesh wound across his
right wrist
Walton was asked what it caused the
wound
as Walton puzzled over the crease in his
wrist the poker game came to a temporary
halt
most of the men playing that night were
on Spike teams or were cubby Riders and
has spent time on the ground
so they knew what RT St Louisiana had
been through finally
Walton said that during the contact with
the grinning NBA soldier who shot the St
Louisiana tail Gunner
one of the rounds from his AK-47 had
creased Walton's wrist
as he was turning his body towards the
NBA Soldier to kill him
everyone sat there for a second and
mazed at how close Walton had come to
being shot
and just how fortunate he was that the
nva's round hadn't inflicted a more
serious wound
just Shrugged his shoulders and the game
continued
yeah
and then when at the at the end of this
chapter
when you and I had an interview back in
July 2002 and you have mentioned
something also you you can do everything
right or wrong and it doesn't matter
Life's a matter of inches
and so you're talking about during this
morning in the ashaw valley you're
carrying an extra pouch of hand grenades
oh yes oh my God in my right thigh right
thigh okay so just as Boggs had
instructed him it hung below the pouches
attached to his web gear down the side
of his leg
the 20 millimeter round that severed his
leg missed it by only a few inches
had that round hit the grenades Pete and
I would have been history that day right
there in the ashaw valley
my God I had forgotten that part in The
Narrative but yes no
and he told you to hang the pouch though
it's you have it below your all your web
gear and everything so I could reach
right down be right in there they were
ready to go oh my God so from um in
another couple of inches on that round
and there's so many times you can sit
here and say but for that I wouldn't be
here if I didn't have the radio on I
wouldn't be here yeah if I'd got hit
just a little bit higher on my leg I
wouldn't be here uh you know if Captain
Ting hadn't brought the helicopter back
down yeah I wouldn't you know and again
the other two got shot out yeah and Tin
comes back oh my God
yeah yeah it just proves to me it proves
the fortunes of War if you want the good
luck bad luck
uh all mixed in there together I can't
you know
just the way it it ended up
that we got out
and uh
because from an observer's perspective
who is like a hundred miles away safe
and F will be one we all thought the
team was done
because we could hear the cubby traffic
and noted
that the team had been overrun when a
Recon team gets overrun usually that's
finito that's the end of the ball game
for that team and in 1968 earlier we had
several teams that were literally
overrun that were wiped out and we had
St Alaska with John Allen who got
overrun and that had ongoing fire fight
and John was the only one to survive to
come back and then early we had St ASP
other teams and even as we talked last
night talked about Phil villarosa one of
the first Recon missions out of fob Ford
Danang in January 1st of 68. and that
team got everybody's killed us at one
American
and he came back and the Envy left them
live because they wanted to come back to
talk about to tell what the NVA did to
them
and so you're all part of that that uh
Carnage that was going on
and the casualties of War because the
secret Wars it turns out had the highest
cavity rate the entire war was exceeded
100 percent
and you're part of that history and
you're likely to be here to talk about
it today on on the brief we got uh that
I received before we got inserted uh
they gave us a little history of that
particular Target area and I was told my
memory is that we had lost one whole
team in there
uh about six months earlier wow no
kidding yeah yeah there's several
targets the teams that even wiped out or
hit so hard it took them a few months to
get back into being an operational
strength again and that's part of the
reasons we thought we weren't going to
actually succeed in inserting was the
area was so
known to be hot well then and then to
follow up say yeah we're going to go in
confirm the enemies here so they can
come in with an arc light yes but and
don't delay exiting yeah you don't want
to be on the wrong end of an arc plate
you don't want to be in the ground when
this happens like oh my God so uh after
August 3rd on the fourth you're at the
hospital you get a Medevac to Japan what
happens from there uh went to excuse me
went to Japan uh Camp SEMA the hospital
there
they tried to do they tried to close my
leg had not been they were unable to
close my leg at the field Hospital in
Vietnam
so they tried again in Japan and they
were not able to do that in Japan
uh
I had been told going into the surgery
that if they couldn't close it I would
put a cast on my leg and ship me back to
the United they'd put a cast on my
residual limb and send me back uh to the
Estates when I woke up from surgery
I found that I could
I could move my fingers right I couldn't
move any other part of my body oh I was
in a full body Spiker cast from my neck
down my good leg
and with my residual with traction built
into the cast for my residual limb
a body cast a body cast
oh my God what that
I I never heard this side okay well you
know yeah it's a fall aftermath yeah
sure so I'm shipped back to the states
in a full body Spiker cast body cast
and we fly from Japan to Alaska
we stopped someplace and people who know
the military base is better than I ever
will might know where we stopped we
stopped someplace in the United States
uh mid-country
and they took us off the
airplane put us into the ward
for an overnight stay
and again I don't know if I I don't know
what I've told you in the past so it was
so long ago they put me in this bed and
I looked down and I've got maggots
crawling out of my no out of my cast
and I still so I call a medic over and I
said you know what's that
because I'm I I'm in a drug State yeah I
mean it keeping me pretty well drugged
uh so I wasn't even sure what I was
seeing at that particular point the
medic grabs a couple puts them in a jar
runs off and by the time he comes back I
know they're maggots and I know that I
you know my brain starts working and
that's yeah that's not a problem in fact
it's common medical practice to throw
maggots into an open wound because
maggots will not eat good flesh they
only eat decaying flesh well and we had
that operation Tailwind where the medic
was Mike Rose yeah and They Carried
wounded personnel and it was one of the
subtitles in that book there about
that operation Tailwind maggots help SF
medic oh absolutely and it's just like
that's what you're and they put it in
the cast
uh they put it in the cast okay yeah
they put them in the cast and uh
so we stayed overnight there uh it was
not a pleasant uh night over there was
um
can
you're gonna edit some of this if we
have to yes okay
well I'm in the cast and after they
found the mega maggots and I'm sitting
there going you know I've got I've got
to defecate I've got yeah
we're we're too busy we don't have a
bedpan
I'll just go to bed
oh my God
yes okay yeah so you do yeah and I did
uh but that was like I said it started
to get a little rough
uh on on that
um and they would rather clean the bed
than get a bed pan
really yeah I don't understand that at
all neither do I but uh it's not the
choice I would have made and either as
The Medic or orderly or the patient uh
but when you gotta go trust me you gotta
go indeed um
so the next morning they fly me from uh
and I'm not alone there's several other
you know it's a Plane full of wounded
guys sure
um and you're cleaned up and Polished a
little bit by that point but at that
time I'm I'm still in the full body
Spiker cast so oh
and uh I'm spread eagle in the cast if
you can imagine yeah there's a maybe a
inch and a half two inch slit
in the groin butt area and that's it
uh
and at that hospital they really did
dispensing patients all over the place
so a group of us go to the east coast
it's like triage yeah where are we going
to send you yeah uh you know again you
don't have an act of saying it it's just
they're looking at uh your wounds your
ability where are you from uh so they uh
send me to dicks we landed dicks Fort
Dix New Jersey next New Jersey yeah uh
in route to Valley Forge Pennsylvania
this Army hospital that was an Army
hospital in Valley Forge right yeah and
they put me on this
it was not really an ambulance an
ambulance bus
um I'm the only stretcher case everybody
else is walking wounded able ambulatory
yeah
and this I
this medic comes by
Excuse me while I because this is this
is another where where did you feel pain
okay no he comes by I'm on this I'm to
travel up to that point had been fine
yeah and this guy looks at me and says
you know your legs cannot exceed the
confines of your stretcher
so he takes my two legs or my one leg
and the residual limb in the traction
and he pushes them together
you know yeah yeah okay so I'm now
within Rex I'm now in the confines of
the stretcher
which
did a lot of damage to my my back had
been obviously hurt when I got here
right so and that's one of the reasons
they had put me in the Spiker cast is
because of my back your back I never
even thought about that so
when they compress my legs together that
put a lot of pressure back on my back
and the ambulance driver decides not he
is unaware that this is happening he
decides that he's going to take the
scenic route to Valley Forge General
Hospital through Valley Forge Park
and halfway through the park somebody
noticed that I was you got a piece of
white paper here I was turning white and
pale
from the pain from the pain they had no
medic on board you had no Keller this
time no rainbow just no pure peso was
just pure pain
uh and discomfort and I was obviously
getting into physical distress not I'm
not I don't think dangerous areas just
really distressful areas
they got me to Valley Forge and this is
at I don't know how many days I'd been
in the body cast
um
so they take me into the hospital
and the first thing they want to do is
see my the state of my residual limbs so
they're going to cut me out of the body
cast
at that when they did so my dressings of
the wound had become part of me or I had
become part of them yeah
and that was
the highest pain level I've ever had it
was like being skinned alive it was
worserer yes yes yes yes yes it was
worse or Earth yes it was
you could tell I'm an English major
absolutely and you write off and and
speak well yeah
oh my God
and they have to tear that stuff off
your skin and I passed out from that
which is thankful yeah yes
but it screws up my pain level uh test
now when you go to somebody and say uh
you know how what's your level of your
pain tendering the worst you ever had
yeah yeah my 10 is very high yeah
I've had really high tense before
so you know my nines really high too
yeah
but it screws off that and then I spent
16.
16 months in the hospital in Valley
Forge no kidding yeah
eight a plus every other every three to
four weeks I was having a major
operation
really that many operations
and
what would the so at that point you're
just trying to get everything
reconstructed so at some point you could
have a prosthesis the first couple of
operations were just trying to close the
wound right uh and then I had to have
skin grafts uh because they couldn't
uh through the traction they try to
stretch the skin
uh they tried to close the wound I still
had open areas on the wound so I had to
go through skin grafts which was
a relatively minor operation but right
they take your skin from a part of your
body skin from my left thigh and
transported over to my residual level
and then they're doing uh what they call
revisions of the residual limb trying to
get it to a reasonable shape sure
um then the last surgery I had they were
going to
tie the they had a new procedure that
they were experimenting with on tying
the ends of the muscle into the end of
the residual bone okay before they just
overlap them over the bone right they
were going to actually tie it in to the
Bone and they thought that gave a better
shape and a longer
um useful life of the residual limb
right but the
antagon
dumb stuff okay
bad luck okay they prepped me they get
me down to the surgery room I go on
anesthesia and the doctor there's only
one Doctor Who can perform this
specialized surgery and he's not
available
so they just do a normal small revision
no yeah after all that after all that
and uh then the major doctor on the
those major lanu who was the doctor of
the ward
uh after that surgery you know they
apologize we didn't do what we wanted to
do but at that point I've been there 14
15 months oh my God and they said you
would benefit from having this surgery
but it's not critical
and it's probably more important for you
to leave
to get out of the hospital and get on
with life we gotta get out of this place
yeah
and so after how many surgeries Tom
I lost count but I was roughly eight oh
yeah you know
little things you remember coming out of
surgery the nurse that you've been
trying to impress indeed comes over and
says how are you doing and you throw up
on her oh no oh yes we go through this
whole Class Act
oh no after one of the search and and it
takes a while for your body to know that
you for the rest of your body to know
that you've lost your limb
uh so because you could feel I remember
what you told me I thought you said you
could still feel or you thought you were
feeling your toes and you're I could you
could get down you can uh feel your arch
your uh your foot yeah uh you so you can
bend that
um and then you slowly lose some of that
your foot in abstentia yeah so it's not
phantom pain no because it was not it's
uncomfortable but it's not painful
because you you know it's not there's
nothing there and a guy a doctor will
come by and say well show me if you can
bend your knee
and usable and then they'll watch the
muscles on your residual limb if you can
work yeah
but again it's uncomfortable but it's
not
painful
uh but one of the after one of the
surgeries I I won't say I forgot I lost
my leg but okay you get out of bed and
you try to take a step right
all right only there's nothing to what's
missing here something is missing but
not the floor hello
you'll be able to do a plf at least no I
just a flat forward fall thank you very
much you look you feel ridiculous
and uh
so that your body is constantly learning
how to adjust with these in traumatic
injuries yeah I can't imagine constantly
but from
the hospital I uh got placed on tdrl
temporary disability retired list
um and uh enrolled it back at
Northeastern University to finish my
undergraduate degree
and while I was there I met there was a
SF Captain with the ROTC program dick
smoosh who was running a kind of gorilla
program
really and I approached him and said you
know can I do anything can I help yeah I
became a unofficial advisor to the ROTC
program oh no kidding University for a
couple of years
and partly because of that there's a
couple of officers that uh
went to SF and completed their whole
career in SF no kidding you still stay
in touch with them still stay in touch
with him yep oh how cool is that yeah so
then after you get your degree somewhere
you meet this lovely lady
and um oh I meant uh
the woman I married indeed uh
I met her the first year I got back at
Northeastern University really yeah and
uh she was finishing her last year as I
was restarting so we had one year of a
terrific romance yeah and then she goes
home
to where Rome New York oh
and uh we were not able to successfully
maintain a long-distance relationship at
that particular time right and the
details of all that doesn't really
matter but we were not yes indeed so I
graduate uh
mess around for a couple years does that
include Soldier of Fortune time well
we'll get there we're coming up to that
and I decide uh
73 74 area uh
that I would like to learn how to fly an
airplane if I could
so I enrolled in a Aviation school out
in Denver Colorado and go out to Denver
and apply for a year
I've got 500 Plus hours single engine
land got my license
thought maybe I'd go for my commercial
license but I suffer from
one of the after effects of this whole
story is I get concussion headaches
which are like migraine headaches
so turbulence really triggers those off
ooh and I found that while I could
manipulate all the controls with my art
I mean that was one of the interesting
things of can you actually use an
artificial egg to fly an airplane and
yeah you absolutely can
and can you use one when you're above
the knee amputee which is different than
we had a British Aviator had lost a leg
or two and continued to fly if you've
got to your knee there's a lot of things
you can do if you don't have your knee
it gets a little bit more challenging
more challenging okay and uh one of the
flight instructors I had just as again
small antidotes he had a box of matches
yeah he broke off the heads of him and
if I wasn't flying correctly he'd shake
them and say I've got termites in here
you know
and learn
but after a year of flying I realized
that commercial
applying commercially yeah was not going
to work for me
um
I couldn't see myself as a bus driver in
the air right which is what a lot of
commercial flying is go out and drive a
bus for whatever
uh so I went back to New England
back to New Hampshire
and
decide that's when I wrote Bob Brown who
was on in Boulder Colorado and we became
who at the time was editor and publisher
and today is still the editor publisher
who Soldier Fortune Magazine uh and that
was when he was just starting the
magazine
and I don't know where I got it I can't
remember where I got his information
right
but we became friends through mail and I
decided not because of that friendship
but for other reasons to go to the
University of Colorado and Boulder and
work on my master's degree in
telecommunications Engineering
Management
uh okay
so I go out to Boulder and that's where
Bob lives to this day to this day in
Boulder uh and we stay in touch and he
says one times you want to come down for
join us for dinner
and I joined him for dinner and I won't
say the rest of that relationship is
history but for the next from 1975
approximately through 1981.
uh I worked with uh Bob or for Bob
depending upon one's point of view
since I didn't get paid it's more with
than four uh but during that
relationship with Bob uh I went to
Africa for three times
I really spent uh yeah uh three
different years uh one of the years I
went and traveled with uh Jim Boland
sure from SOG yes uh and uh he ran out
of CC's sscs yeah
he came up wanted to go so we went uh
together with uh retired Air Force
officer by the name of Dana durenkowski
uh and on that trip they had
the national pistol competition shoot
was being held in
Rhodesia
really so we went and covered that I got
invited to shoot at that shoot not as a
contestant but to shoot some of the
stages sure and that was the first time
I met Jeff Cooper uh who had the America
the who was there with the American team
shooting
I met Ian Smith the prime minister of
Rhodesia wow
during one of the trips met uh Robin
Moore uh the author of The Green Berets
indeed a book he was running a The
Unofficial Embassy of the United States
called the crippled Eagles
oh
which was a watering hole for EX parts
and other Americans and other Nationals
foreign Nationals that were in Rhodesia
at that particular time
and I don't know if you know Vernon
Gillespie no only by name yeah bye again
SF luncheon uh he helped put down the
mountain yard Rebellion right he was
working with Robin Moore
in South Africa at that time wow uh so I
uh wrote a couple of uh articles for Bob
uh
and
met some very good people Al Ventures uh
one of the uh people that Bob was
associated with in southern Africa he
writes very good books on South African
history
so traveled to both uh southern Africa
South Africa the Republic of South
Africa Rhodesia walked in because I had
to walk in to Mozambique no hey if
you're there and you're on the border
and Mozambique is right over there and
there's a little stream I've been there
I've been there thank you very much so
did that spent uh
through through that I met uh
blanking here for a second went up to
mon Botswana
and spent with Harry Selby Harry Selby
was uh a very
white Hunter out of Kenya
during the mama Revolution and lost his
uh
license in Kenya After the Revolution
he wrote the book he is the fictional
character in the book uh Rock's book
um
something of value
is built around his character okay and
his successes in Rhodesia excuse me in
Kenya against the mama
Revolution but he was running a Hunting
Preserve on the edge of uh the okobanko
swamp so I got to spend New Year's in
Christmas with he and his family 50
miles inside the swamp oh and he was
tagging and I'm sorry for those who I do
not know the difference between an
alligator and a crocodile but uh so we
were he was
he was shifting out of hunting uh
safaris into photographic safaris and
Game Preserve
wow efforts yeah so that's why I did for
Bob for and through Bob I've worked with
um
he had a parachute medical rescue
Service uh that he tried to stand up
right so I was a director of that for a
while one of several directors
and he also uh was running a
organization called a refugee relief
International
and another SF guy medic by the name of
Tom Risinger was ahead of that with Doc
Peters I know right okay
so I went to El Salvador twice with
those projects yeah uh
and trying to think of oh and he had a
marketing
uh Branch Phoenix Associates so I
I did that for uh
selling catalogs for a buck a piece
thank you very much oh I'd be surprised
how much money comes in on a buck a
piece catalog
uh back in the 80s now yeah no we're
still in the 70s 70s okay uh the trips
to uh El Salvador with uh
Refugee relief International tripped
over into
um the 80s the early 80s right
um but in 1980 I went to law school at
Franklin Pierce Law Center in Concord
which is now University of New Hampshire
school of law I think absorbed and I
went there to concentrate in law science
uh technology interface
and in between all of this I rement the
lady that I met at Northeastern
University and we ended up getting
married
and he had two children and two children
and dumb me our first wedding
anniversary spent in El Salvador oh
because I didn't even didn't even look
at the calendar oh no Bob called up and
said I'd like to go we're running a
relief we're going to send down some
medical supplies and other things would
you like to come and I said sure
yeah okay mistake well you know it
worked out well but it was a mistake for
that early enough you learned she was a
forgiving caring loving woman indeed no
sarcasm there at all she was yeah that's
a whole lot better person than I was ah
um but we had two children uh she had
one from her first marriage and who I
adopted and a son from our marriage and
unfortunately my wife passed away
1994. I said 94 94. 44 years old
um
and my legal career at Frank's at
Franklin Pierce Law Center
uh
again we'll go into a little bit of uh
yeah do you like the trauma of your
Vietnam vet you're applied to a law
school that has a very active National
lawyers Guild uh organization on campus
which is extremely uh more to the left
of center sure and we had Frank's had a
participatory admission student
participatory admission panel
so when I got accepted at Frank's I went
for an oral interview over one of the
holidays one of the school holidays I
forget was Nate offered they accepted my
application they uh approved it
and the national lawyers killed members
on campus became upset that they had not
been able to participate in this in the
vetting so they could in the vetting
knock you out of the box and uh
and they were very concerned about my
military activities having been SF and
then having a relationship with Bob
Brown in those activities right as to
whether I would fit into their unique
student body
so we I had to do a second interview
and uh
that was obviously successful you had to
convince them you weren't a baby killer
well yeah or
I think the biggest diffusion of it came
from when they were asking me a bunch of
questions or whatever and they got down
to my activities with SF and being
Greenbrier and being SOG being uh
and they weren't sure that those would
fit and I I had my response to them was
generally I don't have a problem with
your politics
I don't have a problem with what you've
done or what you plan to do
you supposedly say you are liberal and
yet you are saying you have a problem
with mine
oh
good arguments though you know I can get
along with you
and I'm not supposedly the liberal yeah
and uh
and it worked it as far as it I handled
that interview fine apparently because I
got in they unanimously said okay and
I went uh through Frank's for three
years
oh one other little
sidebar one little sidebar on the
interview one of the members of the
student uh panel
uh was a guy by the name of uh L Scott
paulinsby
uh and what I did not know at the time
Scott was a Vietnam veteran
and he asked me
came time to a panel questions and he
asked me one of the most stupid
questions I had ever heard trying to
interview for admission to law school
yeah which I don't have to repeat here
because uh well he asked me if I knew
what a Seer pin was
a Seer pin yeah I'm here trying to get
into law school and this guy do you know
what a crin is uh so I told him I did
and what it was uh and walked away from
that the interview with that was a
stupid ass question
and I meet Scott a couple of weeks later
after I start school
and he comes up and he says
you know I was trying to signal to you
that you had a friend on the panel
and I said well Scott that signal went
way over my head
thank you
but uh Scott graduated from law school
and eventually uh worked for the
Department of State in the Diplomatic
Security uh
Department safety and became uh head of
their anti-terrorist organization
yeah wow he is also now passed laying at
rest at Arlington
but that was my in my introduction into
law school and while I was there I
became involved I got asked invited by
the president of the university to of
college of law school to um
get a president panel
to try to figure out new directions for
the school so he invited me to work on
that and oh wow I did that's a real
honor yeah and then there was a separate
program being run by uh
a follow from the Department of State
and they were trying to work the legal
aspects of
could the United States especially
Northern New England and Canada Quebec
uh
was it going could they form a joint
economic relationship on power sharing
electrical power sharing right so we did
a whole thought piece on that for this
uh Secretary of State
uh on that was a very interesting
project looking at the Bay of Fundy
tides and sure Hydro Quebec and
uh try seeing whether you I won't say a
created economic dependency but a mutual
independent uh dependency yeah sure and
one of the ideas was if
Quebec came a little bit more
economically dependent upon US Dollars
than the free Quebec movement might be
tapped down considerably
so that was interesting that my third
year I worked as a intern for the New
Hampshire Supreme Court for one of the
uh Associates whoa that must have been a
real honor that was it was and
insightful too it was I was the one of
the first two students uh one other guy
in my class
to
be offered to work for the Supreme Court
in an interim position so we broke the
ground there there's been several others
since then since then but that was uh
it's nice to be first indeed
occasionally and the others had to live
up to your high standards that you set
being the first oh no it's real easy
real easy to jump over that hurdle now
now no problem and then I uh interviewed
uh was I was getting ready to graduate I
interviewed for a job with a high-tech
electronic tech company because that's
what I thought I wanted to do yeah
and
they will remain anonymous and do for
this purpose I got invited for the
interview I applied got invited for the
interview went down to their corporate
headquarters in Massachusetts
met with us very nice guy
but one of his initial questions to me
was did I have any idea of the size of
the law department for that company
and we're in a high-rise yeah
building and I said no honestly I did
not maybe I should have but I didn't and
it's what we occupy two floors of this
whole building
okay and he says next question is do you
know how many of our lawyers are Vietnam
veterans
oh
and I again said no and he said there is
one
no kidding there is one
and I had at that point I was talking I
was told I was talking to him
and he very bluntly explained that the
company did not generally
higher Vietnam veterans uh we know how
they are so yep again know how that is
this is 1983 though okay yeah yeah
uh thank you I thought time had passed
here some residual uh you know yes was
was not a big issue
uh so that did not develop into a job
offer and as many careers go you go
where the job offers take you so from
there I went into criminal prosecution
because that's where the job the job
offer I got
so I worked for the police department uh
in Southern New Hampshire for two years
again and I'll tell this just because
they are
um I guess it's somewhat important to
understand that we sometimes are really
with strange people so I get I get an
interview with the selectman for the
town three persons like people and and
the chief is with me and who's to select
people because this is a different
language than what we hear other cities
like councilmen council members okay
yeah
um they run the town yes they make the
hiring and firing decisions
and so I'm going through this oral
interview the chief is there sponsoring
me uh on they're trying to reorganize
the police department for uh they've had
a real at that point they had a big
problem with corruption and they'd had
to remove several police officers wow
and so they were trying to upgrade the
professionalism of the department
had hired a new Chief they wanted to
hire a professional prosecutor
so at some point in this interview one
of the
councilman slugman
asked me you know not
you are disabled right I said yes that
means you're getting compensation from
the government right
yes well how much are you getting no
whereupon
my draw just dropped like yours yeah
yeah that's not a question I really
anticipate but before I could even
formulate and answer one of the other
stuff and goes that's none of your
business
and so I'm sitting there on this
interview with the two two of the three
Selectmen arguing with each other as to
uh the basis of my compensation rather
it should be reduced because I was
oh my God
we got through that yes they hired me
and so I worked as a district court a
lower court uh prosecutor Prosecuting uh
violations and misdemeanors for two
years for the police department and
conducting in-house professional
training for the law enforcement
office upgrading their standards along
the way trying to yeah um
and uh from there I went to the
Rockingham County Attorney's Office I
got hired his assistant County attorney
which would be like District Attorneys
elsewhere
uh where we prosecuted felony cases
every every felony up to murder the
murders are done by the aeg's office
Attorney General's office for the State
of New Hampshire
and again after I got hired
uh the County Attorney after been there
about nine months sitting down we'd
become friends I got to tell you Tom you
know
we weren't sure we were going to hire
you that's why because of your SF
background we were not what we weren't
sure that you could fit into our unique
Community yes uh that you would be
flexible enough uh to be able to work
the prosecutional side but you proved to
the you're the epitome of flexibility oh
I am so flexible that is unreal uh but
that you know yeah uh the stereotypic
Vietnam vet thinking yes without
realizing what SF is and that persisted
and now we're talking uh 86 87.
oh my God yeah of course it was there
you're saying you know sometimes you
think those issues are behind you when
they are still there in in your face and
you just don't know it people are making
those decisions oh yeah uh and you've
got no idea why they're making uh the
basis of those decisions sure
but I had a very good uh experience in
the Rockingham County Attorney's Office
enough so that the County Attorney sent
me down to there's a prosecution School
in Houston Texas
he sat me down there four times uh wow
to get specialized training in different
tools your prosecutorial too yes learned
a lot yeah
and then I moved to the
department of safety for the State of
New Hampshire they have administrative
hearings
where they adjudicate or or you it's a
Civil Trial or an administrative trial
if somebody has violated the various
rules of the Department of Safety uh
whether it be motor vehicle licensing or
Hazmat Transportation uh so it's a
quasi-judicial role that I filled in
another system it would be in a A
administrative law judge position sure
the state of New Hampshire doesn't have
that
uh well everything's a little different
new here well everything you have Live
Free or Die State indeed absolutely no
but the bench the judicial bench is very
uh guarded of their Authority sure so
every time in New Hampshire where this
has come up as an issue and say we want
to convert these Administrative Hearings
to administrative law judges hearings
the judicial branch says no basically we
have judges
and you're not
uh and that's true but I did everything
that a judge does on an administrative
level sure uh so you the uh adjudicator
you try you know that judge who presides
you're the judge and jury yeah all
wrapped up in one you make conclusions
to the law find uh findings of facts and
then you impose sanctions and
consequences
and then you're also uh they expand the
position where you're the official
a Record Keeper for the department so
you go to court as a state witness when
the records of the department are being
challenged yeah
and I did that for 24.
24 25 years wow so and retired
thank you would you retire that's a good
question last year don't ask me that no
I won't answer the question is not asked
Tom no don't ask that again that's been
answered thank you very much indeed no
uh I'm trying to think I've been retired
for a for a good while now for a good
while indeed was that back when you
became the executive director for the
Special Operations Association
after I retired indeed and I became the
executive director for six years at
least six yeah but again it's just for
our listeners who may have never heard
of either the Special Operations
association with the veterans group of
SOG formed by SOG and then expanded to
include aviators that supported so I'll
go over the years over the operations
across the fence and they had a board of
directors and during that time the board
had hired executive director the only
salaried position and in came you yes
helping to bring focus and proven to the
board and of course A lot of times you
wound up doing things that some of the
presidents or other board members should
have done yes you were kind enough to
get it done that job expanded it had no
limits
none whatsoever and never a pay raise
nope no and that was what we stood up at
the SL Special Operations Association
started in 1978 six six with Jim Butler
because Jim Butler uh contacted me in
the 70s oh no kidding yeah and asked me
to join yeah and so for three years I
was a director of communications for the
SOA oh no is that right that is very
Inception oh wow yeah I survive at that
point and then uh when I
left Colorado and went to law school I
decided and got married I said law
school and marriage took president over
PR for nothing yep fruit a lot of things
including the SOA so I backed off from
the SOA uh official obligations and
forget when I later reconnected yeah and
started going regularly uh and then got
asked to be the executive director and
that was like a year or two because in
2003 was the only year
that we attended you and I attended soar
together with Tony Harrell and John Wall
and um Sally we lost John I know five
with a spare metal airplane crash and
you had internal Ting there too as well
indeed yes yeah John uh uh flew up to
Fargo North Dakota and his private jet
picked up Colonel Chen his wife and his
son flew him back to the reunion paid
for everything had a special dinner out
with the family and then flew him back
after the reunion just to say thanks and
the first time I met Tony after Nam was
at one of our reunions oh is that right
yeah and uh
we spent
the good part of for those who do not
know we have a hospitality suite when we
have our reunion which has an open bar
and ah stays open till one or two
o'clock in the morning depending upon
your ability to getting a little bit
older you're cutting the hours back to
about midnight cutting those hours back
but uh ran into Tony there and we sat
down and talked uh talked out a lot of
things sure um and I was surprised how
much
Survivor guilt Tony had at that
particular Point certainly uh and
because I didn't I didn't see
him coming off the team
as
having anything to do with me getting
injured right or blown I saw those as
separate events sure and Tony did not
see those as separate events he had
haunted him yeah and it did yeah but we
sat down and over
I don't know how much they've got a
couple drinks yeah yeah one or two
drinks
light ones yes indeed a lot of ice no
you know water a little alcohol but we
talked that out and I think that was
that was good for both of us oh
absolutely I know he talked to me about
it he did he really enjoyed it and the
course of your part of the team every
year we get together if we can oh and
that is something we need to talk about
off the Record indeed
and last but not least another part of
the SOA is the SOA Riders which has
raised funds for the SOA as well as
working on raising the consciousness of
issues for our pow and Mias yes
and that is uh we stood that up now what
about 10 years ago at least well Larry
Trimble was the first uh director of the
SOA Riders Then followed by Tom Carroll
and today your good friend Marcus Witt
Marcus Whitton has picked up the
gauntlet and run with it and every year
we do a ride of four to five days
duration at the conclusion of the ride
we do a ceremony honoring uh and
remembering our Mias we lay a wreath at
an appropriate veteran site and lay a
carnation for every one of our Mias
still unaccounted for indeed as of today
there's
1583 they just brought home the remains
of an Air Force uh pilot
but these are still the Americas that
are still Mis listed as missing in
action and Southeast Asia from the
Vietnam War was in all of Vietnam
Laos Cambodia Thailand and a couple from
China yeah
and it's it we get to show the SOA uh
we get to show the public that the SOA
exists Special Operations exist right
and now we have the joint SOA Special
Forces Association powmi committee that
Mike Taylor chairs and Mike was the uh
our last guest for sawcast number 10.
and Mike's been very active and done
great work through that committee there
yeah for a while we weren't we were sort
of treading water on the Mia issue as an
organization that's why we brought in
Mike and Mike has squared that away he
has we are quite active now in in that
uh Arena yeah we should say that the
national league of powmia families the
CEO chairman
and griffith Mills said that this is the
most proactive for that mission of any
veterans group in the United States
which is a real feather in the cap of
Mike yes it is and the members of the
committee and it's very important to our
membership oh incredible extremely
important yeah because that today
there's still 50 Green Berets that are
missing in action
from the secret war that were across the
fence and then you throw in 80 plus
aviators
and this coming reunion in October that
all those missing and Nationals will be
commemorated at the reunion in October
in Vegas and did you know how active Bob
was in that
because he was oh very active yeah very
very active he committed a lot of uh
Personnel time personal time yes and
Financial Resources been trying to big
bucks even on a couple of Adventures
that turned sideways on them but he
tried no I just wanted to get that we
had to Bob Brown's one of our heroes we
might line him up for a sogcast someday
it's he's done a lot of good work yeah
I'll tell you that he may be very
controversial and he
has his own we all have our own we do
and he may be the only Green Beret
officer who was this thrown out of
country twice
yeah but we'll talk about that more
later any uh any closing thoughts there
as we wrap this up for today
uh no I don't think so I think we've
done you've picked my brain as much as
it's a hell of a story Tom I'll never
forget it and I'll never forget that
interview that led to the story
so with that thought thank you oh yeah
well no we thank you
um we want to thank all the veterans out
there men and women who serve our
country today men like Tom Cunningham
who stepped up to serve our country who
fought for the ideals of our country
truly an American Hero
to those of you out there on the front
lines today we thank you for fighting
for all of our values and for our
country we also thank the police law
enforcement border patrol
all of our military services Army Air
Force Navy Marines Coast Guard and yes
the space force and we thank to all
those that have given up their lives for
our country and for those who didn't
come home today we say thank you
and we close by saying that we have
the sog podcast are available now
they're being posted on Spotify apple
and eventually would be on podcast and
someday might come out as YouTubes but
it's part of a production program and
you can go to my website which is uh
www.chronicles.com and it's a podcast
are posted they will be listed there
also so again Tom we thank you for
coming out today
and we want to thank Jocko Productions
and saw Chronicles for for co-hosting
this latest show sogcast number 11.
thank you God bless America
Airborne all the way